susana compro más manzanas que plátanos
y compro más plátanos que melones
digamos que a representa las manzanas
que compro susana que ve es el número de
plátanos y que se representa el número
de melones compara las expresiones de
más c&a cual enunciado es el correcto
bmc es mayor que a bmc es menor que a
demás c es igual a o no existe
suficiente información para responder a
esto y como siempre los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
por su cuenta
y ahora vamos a resolver esto juntos
vemos qué información nos dan a
representar las manzanas que representa
los plátanos y ce los melones nos dicen
que tenemos más manzanas que plátanos
así que tenemos a mayor que ve y también
nos dicen que tenemos más plátanos que
melones así que va a ser mayor que se y
podemos reescribir esto como a mayor que
b mayor que se o también podemos
reescribir esto como c menor que b menor
que a esta es la información que nos dan
veamos cuál de estas opciones será
correcta la primera es b más mayor que a
una cosa que podemos hacer es tratar de
poner algunas cantidades aquí para ver
si podemos obtener combinaciones que
coincidan con algunas de estas opciones
y si no cae en algunas de estas opciones
puedes diremos que no existe suficiente
información y en general esta es una
buena estrategia cuando tratamos con
cantidades muy abstractas
vamos a dibujar una tabla aquí para a
para ver para hacer y otra columna para
ver más y compararemos esto con a veamos
si podemos hacer que demás sea mayor que
a
se tiene que ser menor que ikea así que
digamos que se es igual a 5 b va a ser
igual a 6 día va a ser igual a 7 aquí
tenemos que ve más se va a ser igual a
11 pudimos encontrar una situación en
donde vemos que es cercano a y vemos que
es b más se es mayor que a así que ya
pudimos encontrar este escenario veamos
si podemos encontrar otro escenario en
donde más se sea menor que a podemos
hacer que b y se tengan los mismos
valores y podemos hacer a mayor que
demás digamos que es 12 en la primera
situación teníamos que ver más se era
mayor que a y en esta segunda situación
tenemos que vemos que es menor que a así
que dependiendo del valor que tengan
nuestras a b y c y se cumplan con estas
restricciones que nos indican en el
problema
recuerden que nos dicen que a es mayor
que b y b es mayor que se podemos tener
cualquiera de estos dos enunciados
lo que nos lleva a decir que no existe
suficiente información incluso podría
encontrar un escenario en donde más se
sea igual a por ejemplo 6 5 y 11 y así
ve más se será igual a por lo que con
base en la información que nos dan aquí
no existe suficiente información para
decir cuál enunciado es correcto ya que
cualquiera de estos enunciados son
posibles así que no existe la suficiente
información para decidir